قسمه الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
فيما يتعلق بالوثائق السريه تعود لتطفو
على سطح مجددا الرئيس الامريكي السابق كلف
شركه خاصه بتفتيش اربعه عقارات بعد توجيه
قاد فيدرالي باتجاه البحث بجديه اكبر عن
اي مواد سريه لا تزال في حوذات ترامب
التفتيش قاد الى العثور على وثيقتين على
الاقل تحمل تصنيف سري داخل صندوق مغلقه في
موقع تخزين تديره الحكومه الفيدراليه ما
دفع محامي ترامب لاختار وزاره العدل
بشانها عمليات التفتيش شملت منزل الرئيس
السابق في فلوريدا ومنتجع غولف تابع
لترامب بولايه نيوتيرسي اضافه لبرج ترامب
الواقع في نيويورك لتجنب اشكالات قانونيه
ضد الرئيس السابق بحسب محمد
وزاره العدل ابلغوا محامي الرئيس السابق
انهم يعتقدون انه ربما والديه المزيد من
المواد السريه التي لم تتم اعادتها
متحدث باسم ترامب قال ان الرئيس السابق
وفريق محاميه يوصلون العمل بشفافيه وتعاون
كامل مع وزاره العدل الامريكيه
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي سبق له تفتيش
منزل الرئيس السابق ترامب في فلوريدا في
الثامن من اغسطس بحثا عن وثائق سريه
اضافيه وسجلات رئاسيه اخرى عندما فتش
عناصر الاف بي اي منتجع مارالاجو عثروا
على وثائق سريه تبتسم بحساسيه كبيره لدرجه
ان موظفي مكافحه التجسس التابعين للمكتب
ومحامي وزاره العدل احتاجه الى التصاريح
اضافيه قبل ان يسمح لهم بالاطلاع على
وثائق محدده نيورك تايمز قالت انه بينما
تستمر وزاره العدل في طرح اسئله حول
المستندات المفقوده حتى الان
نقل مصدر في الوزاره انه لا يوجد حاليا
سبب محتمل قد يدفع مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي للحصول على امر قضائي لتفتيش
مقرات اخرى لترامب اصل الحكايه يرجع الى
سؤال الارشيف الوطني المتكرر خلال العام
الماضي عن بعض المواد التي كان يجب ان
ترسل للمقر الذي يحتفظ بالوثائق الرئاسيه
الا ان المستشارين ترامب اكدوا ان
الصناديق المنقوله من البيت الابيض مليئه
باغراض شخصيه فيما اوضح مسؤول الارشيف
الوطني ان قصاصات الصحف يمكن اعتبارها
سجلات رئاسي
[موسيقى]
باب التوازي مع تحقيق وزاره العدل تجري
لجنه في الكونجرس تحقيقا موازيا بشان
الوثائق السريه بحوزه ترامب بحلول الثالث
من يناير سيستلم الجمهوريون تفدا مجلس
النواب باغلبيه ضئيله وستكون مسيطره على
لجان الكونجرس على اختلافها النائب جيمس
كومير الذي من المحتمل ان يكون الرئيس
القادم للجنه الرقابه في مجلس النواب قال
لسان ان التحقيق في الوثائق السريه لن
يكون هذا اولويه في الكونجرس الجديده
محللون قالوا ان اللجنه القضائيه في مجلس
النواب تحت القياده الجمهوريه ستصوب
سهامها باتجاه وزاره العدل وستعمل اللجنه
كفريق دفاعا عن ترامب اضافه التحليل لان
حلفاء ترامب سيتهمون وزاره العدل باضطهاد
ترامب بشكل غير عادي بينما تتغاضى عن
التحقيق بشان عائله بايظن وتحديدا لاجله
هانتر وبحسب توقعات سيطالب الجمهوريون
بالوفاءائق والمصادر الداخليه في كل حاله
تتابعها وزاره العدل بشان ترامب وهو ما
سترفده الوزاره بعدها سيتم اصدار مذكرات
استدعاء للمسؤولين في وزاره العدل
هدف الجمهوريين هنا وفق التحليلات سيكون
تشويه اي قضيه لوزاره العدل ضد ترامب هل
ان هذا الدوافع سياسيه وتصوير ترامب على
انه الضحيه لاستنهاض القاعده الجمهوريه
والاهم محاوله شله تحقيقات بشده
[موسيقى]
فرانكو